what is the coolest new science thing
you've learned to tell me I've learned
cool sign things every day and sometimes
I have to be removed I have to be
reminded of them maybe I knew them long
ago like we all knew that we have very
high common DNA with chimpanzees like
99% identical and it's okay I get that
but do you know we also have 50% common
DNA with a banana
I do love bananas banana there you go
and I got one others for you ready if
you look at the tree of life the common
ancestors between humans and mushrooms
split after what kind of mushrooms after
the common ancestor between our common
ancestor and green plants which means we
and mushrooms are more genetically
connected than either of us are to green
plants what I mean we are like fungus on
a fungus among relationships with
mushrooms be around people you love I'm
more likely to learn a new fact in a
science that's not my specialty yes oh
but I love you if it's out of my
specialty with scientist I'm just
totally lost
Oh subscribe to my channel subscribe to
my channel subscribe to my channel
subscribe to my channel please don't
make me keep going